oh so well you you'll close it out like
yeah all right five four three two one
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki and we are
featuring Gregory Hammonds what's up
thanks for coming out of the show
absolutely happy to be here
hell yeah Greg and I when did we meet we
man that's right at CJ Anderson's a
venue where I'm seeing that event that
was awesome that was like feels like a
year ago right it was a while ago yes
yep yep and that was that was a really
inspirational event and then because
he's working on dreams never die
Foundation yeah that's awesome work and
then um seed the world's fair that we
hosted yes we're in a Mickey Mouse shirt
yeah I loved it I loved it MC between
getting the audience engaged I'm getting
them inspired and between the speakers
so super important when we were hosting
that together and then now we got you on
simulation on the show I've been working
on forever face absolutely for four
years now yeah yes forever face is my
baby you know it's my pride and joy it's
really a part of me and I started at
four years ago just knowing that I
wanted to do something to impact the
world I wanted to have a voice and I
wanted to be entertaining in a way that
was useful and beneficial to a huge
amount of people and so when I was at
Ohio State I figured you know upon
graduation I might not go work in
entertainment immediately because that
was like my primary dream but I was just
like you know what can I do to still
keep this entertainment piece a part of
me and then I said like I'll just create
a company so I created forever phase LLC
which allowed me to continue being an
entertainer because I love acting I love
motivational speaking I love poetry and
spoken word and so forever phase allows
me to do that but it allows me to do
that with a purpose because when I'm
speaking I'm inspiring youth and I think
the youth are the future
actually I know the youth are the future
and so that's what it allows me to do
yeah that vibe is so good yeah it's a
vibe is so strong and I love that about
you you know you really carry that vibe
in your through your heart when you even
speak it you know it sounds so real
that's so important absolutely so ok so
now like four years ago what was this
like when I was first coming up and now
it's now it's workshops and now it's
speaking and motivational speaking
engagements so yeah absolutely so in the
beginning right I just knew that I
wanted to be a motivational speaker in
so funny story when I was maybe like 15
I was at this huge conference and I had
saw this motivational speaker Patricia
McCloud and she was speaking about the
brain right and she was going through
all the intricacies and you know nuances
of the brain and she kept you know she
would dive so deeper than she would pull
back and go broad and like say like this
is why you're powerful this is why you
can do anything you want to do because
the brain has all of these nuances that
make it so you know complex so you're
already inherently able to do crazy
things that you probably wouldn't
imagine you can do and so hearing her
just really put me in a state of mind to
know that one day I want to do that like
I felt that in my heart and so fast
forward to like once I'm in college at
Ohio State and I'm about to graduate and
I'm like going into the real world I'm
like hey momma life is about to change
you know because whatever career I
choose this is what I wake up and do
every day so I'm like I can't let that
passion that dream go and I immediately
just started networking and trying to
figure out how can I become a
motivational speakers so first thing
interesting that moment of Patricia
MacLeod you know there's always these
moments for people in their youth that
trigger them to see the world through an
inspirational light that they decide to
go and like pursue some field like oh
yeah that's good totally and then what
and then actually like in that moment I
got chills right like listening to her I
remember I remember my hands were kind
of shaking and I remember like after she
was in the back like giving it selling
books and I bought her book and I
took her hand and I said you know I want
to be I think I asked her like what
would you tell an inspiring motivational
speaker you know because that's what I
am she was just like you know just work
hard never give up and you know I think
those are like words that you know you
always hear but to know how much he
meant to me in that moment really made
the difference yeah yeah so I think just
fast forward to being at Ohio State and
knowing that I wanted to really get
serious about it it really took me
finding people who could give me a
platform right and I think first things
first I started at copmi college so I
went to business school at Ohio State
I like networked with the business
school and said hey I want to be a
motivational speaker can I talk to the
younger students coming through you know
the program and they were like yeah we
can we can give you a stage when give
you a platform oh yeah so I just like
pull it on things I knew right and it
was just like it was early stage so it
wasn't like I had a ton to say it was
like hey I was just in college classes I
was a part of oryx like this is how I
made it through this is what kept me
inspired but you know I think back then
it may not have seemed like a lot to me
but in those moments to those younger
students you don't never you don't ever
know how people perceive what you're
saying and how valuable it can be so
like me telling them hey study hard to
get to a might have been just what they
needed not to go to a party or not to
get involved with the wrong crowd so I
think you know then it was like really
grassroots in and very young and like
now it is definitely developed into a
lot more
I love how in the collegiate days it was
like that you had some good wisdoms to
share but it was young wisdom you know
yeah because that's how we all start
yeah yeah yeah we all start with like
the rookie status of like we're going
and we're testing things and we're
learning and we're falling on our face a
bit and we're sneaking back up and and
some people are resonating with the
things we're saying and then all of a
sudden it builds up every single year
you get better and better at this art
form yeah and all of a sudden people see
you up on stage and then they're like
damn how do you get there and then that
one that one graphic with all the guy
that's walking up the stairs and then
the stages is on the other side of the
stairs with all the people and he's
juggling plates
in front of the whole audience but then
what you don't see on the stairs is all
the broken plates that led him to that
point that's a jug and they never see
that piece and I think like it's so
important to talk about that process and
that's what I love to bring to my
speeches right whenever I'm talking to
students giving a workshop or a keynote
it's like you need to understand that
life is real and it's filled with so
many events that you won't expect so
many events that will push you back but
what defines you is what you say defines
you and it's hopefully the the power and
the motivation to keep moving forward
because we'll all go through those
things right yeah damn and that power
and motivation to keep moving forward is
so important yeah like and that's not
even just like then the heroines or the
hero's journey but that's also a huge
part of even the way that society is
currently fostering a lot of depression
and anxiety and we see a little bit like
we saw that little spike in suicide a
couple days ago and that that again like
these things are really crucial to
communicate to the world and be there to
just hold space for people to hear their
feelings and to just be with them not
necessarily coach them but you can also
coach them as well you know but holy cow
is it important to persevere through
those those difficulties and move
forward sure and it all pays off it pays
off you know because you get to new
levels that you never thought you would
see and you get to experience things
that like you probably couldn't even
imagine so that is worth it I think
every day it's worth it yeah so okay now
let's touch on the like the the things
that you found to be these like more
wiser things to communicate right there
was this one that we just talked about
the perseverance and grit games through
the lows and continuing onward that is
that kind of one of the central pillars
and like what are the other central
pillars of the things that you like to
to communicate totally all the way I
feel like the perseverance and the grit
piece is like embedded and everything
that I've talked about so it is like
kind of like the baseline it's like the
brick and mortar
and then like through that I kind of go
into different verticals with the
students and so one of those verticals
is brand management and so a lot of us
think of a brand as being you know like
a huge company and like here's like Nike
right like Google like McDonald's right
like these big companies and I think
that it's important to understand your
personal brand and the impact that that
has on your success so I talked to
students a lot about that and I talked
to them about the power that they have
over that brand right it's not only your
image in in the sense of how people see
you but it's also like what are you
doing to build up the credentials and
the resume right to kind of like have
something a piece of paper speak for you
when you're not in the room that's your
brand as well and like you don't only
have you know your brand in terms of
what others are saying about you but
then it's also as soon as I shake your
hand for the first time that immediate
interaction develops a brand right that
first that person-to-person interaction
is also super important so let's let's
unpack this this is getting good okay
all right so the brand management yeah
brand development say okay so there's
the piece of what's what's going on when
you're not around so when someone looks
up your name yep
does the Google search yep is your
website up there yeah and what does what
does your website say about you exactly
are you are you really capturing
someone's attention and they're very
beautifully designed and quick and
concise way right and then and then also
when you first meet someone yeah when
you first meet them in person are you
are you able to make it make it so that
they remember you forever that they're
like that was an amazing interact
forever and not for failure right you
can't make it a phase it has to be
forever that's it yeah yeah no that's so
important and it's just like if you have
that ability and a lot of students who
are coming up right and like going
through high school they might not know
all this but everyone has a short
attention span these days so like you
said you need to be able to grab people
pull them in and I think nowadays it's
not about giving people what you want
them
see but it's more so about giving them
the authentic genuine you yes and that's
why when we were touching on that we
were watching that video earlier of like
that short little hero's journey video
yeah put up
I went vulnerable oh yeah Subin I talked
about here and that struggle that comes
in through and that's really interesting
if somebody sees that that that is
almost a that's almost an invitation it
is versus what we do with the culture of
this is my best moment my best moment my
best moment yeah yes I love that I love
that I love the fact that you said it's
an invitation because it is and I think
so many people feel marginalized today
right so many people feel like they're
pushed out and not accepted for who they
are and to give people an invitation is
that handout in that hand up into the
conversation that I think we need to we
need to foster we had at the security at
the Michael Pollan event we brought on
two of our friends to come and do
security and so they're doing security
there black to black guys doing security
and we have afterward we're talking
about diversity all right so we're
talking about diversity and we're
talking about diversity of women
diversity people of color neural
diversity all this different type of
stuff and you know after the event I
walk up to them and I'm like I'm like
I'm like remember when we were talking
on stage about diversity remember when
we were talking about the importance of
like having time and having space and
having community that fosters the use of
these consciousness expanding substances
and they're like yeah and and we talked
about how we can we can facilitate the
community around where they live to have
people that we know come and facilitate
space and time for them to slowly get
introduced to things that can augment
and expand their consciousness and they
were like hell yeah they're like have
you heard of Flatbush what this and the
Flatbush guys that were the rappers from
Flatbush in Brooklyn
they talked about mushrooms and
importance
mushrooms and so just this this this
like this this edge of inclusivity
totally and knowing how to be inclusive
knowing how to best do that yes because
I think there's a right in a wrong way
and it's so important to just know that
like when you want to include people
include them for them right like and
include them for their sake don't
include them for your sake right and I
think it's important to know that like
if you're bringing everyone to the table
you know and you want everyone's voice
to be heard do it in a way that gives
them the full you know autonomy to run
the show to run what it is that is their
voice and to deliver what it is that
they believe because when people start
you know trying to manipulate situations
and to make things more political I
think it kind of ostracizes the true
intent so yeah but I think you know as
long as we continue to you know push
these images and push brands right like
forever phase and like simulation that
want to you know raise the voices of
everyone and to give everyone's story
the platform that it deserves we'll keep
making good strides yeah so okay so then
these high schoolers are learning about
brand management and they're and you're
making it relatable for them and they're
in there and they're like oh yeah you
know I need to have something that
represents me YES on the internet for
people to see and then they get inspired
to go make to create you talk to them
all the time on the show at the end of
every show we're like don't just consume
this content yeah make stuff with it
that's that's key right and I think well
I know at the end of every one of my
workshops it's always action-oriented
right like what are three things that
you're gonna leave here today and do and
then also who's gonna hold you
accountable so I love to push the
accountability certain parts so
important you know you'll leave and be
like right right and it happens oh it's
so easy because we're all so busy with
everything that goes on our lives but if
you met someone new at a workshop that
you didn't know from a different high
school and then you're like hey I'm
going to take your email down
and remind you you're supposed to go to
sports practice right three times a day
right and I do what you need to do to
get on the team then they'll do it you
know and they believe that they can
actually change their brand so it's
super powerful I think what you just
described also is there's the
accountability piece and then there's
also the piece of this this motivation
from within the house that I'm like you
got it like you got to know that the
time that you invest going to that that
second or third sports practice yes day
is actually more important for you than
staying at home yeah and and and by
going and doing it not only pushing
yourself to your limits and you're
learning about how hard you can go but
you're also about to do things like go
and push yourself farther than other
people can go and then lay in that spot
on the team and then you learn all of
the important things that you learn from
having a team and have having a coach
and having practice having competition
and learning about those dynamics yes so
it's worth the hustle to bring it
through you and going and bring it out
how do you get that part because okay
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah yeah no I think
that's a really good a good point and
it's not always easy because a lot of
people a lot of youth will come and say
like Greg I'm just not naturally
motivated right like that's not my
personality and what I believe is most
helpful in those situation in those
situations is when like I tell my
personal stories right because I'm not
always that guy who can you know just
wake up and put on the smile and just be
motivation right and I like to like let
people know that because a lot of people
get it confused they look at my
Instagram they're like Greg you're
always happy you're always inspiring but
no it takes time and it takes me feeding
off of others people other people's
energy sometimes right it's just like
I'll look at you know Eric Thomas and
get inspired you know the hip-hop
preacher I'll look at Oprah or I'll look
at Joel Osteen and I'm just like I need
other people to kind of inspire me
sometimes and so I let them know that
they are not alone right if you don't
feel like you have that internal drive
but you have to know
that unless you do have that internal
drive you may not get as far and you
have to I'm very honest with the
students you know I let them know hey
success is built off of work
determination and and just being
prepared for the opportunities that are
going to come to you and so if you don't
have that internal drive to get going
you're gonna miss out but don't be
discouraged if you feel like you don't
naturally have it because you can get it
from other places yeah and like you said
that the stories that you say about
yourself not always able to be the
Energizer Bunny of happiness and
motivation Wolf's and and even when you
do talk about the stories that are a
little bit on your like lows on the low
trots
when you get there then they're like
like it's totally cool to be imperfect
and to have these like lows and these
flaws and these more like flaws and then
yeah and then but but you also then
explain how you can rise up rom and go
through that okay so that with the brand
management pillar like the motivation
pillar yeah what are the other pieces so
other pieces another portion that I'll
another topic that I really love to talk
touch on is just being able to have
balance so work social life school
balance because a lot of the youth are
going through a point in their life
where it's just tons of peer pressure
and they don't know necessarily how to
deal with the pressure where their goals
really are because they have teachers
telling them hey you're really smart you
should really be focused in the
classroom but then they may have their
peers telling them hey you're really
beautiful you should be a model or you
should be a TV actor and then they're on
the sports team right they're like yo I
need to really perform because my coach
is gonna be upset with me and so I
really help students understand what it
means to be well-rounded and how to come
to a place within themselves and
understand that like hey I'm a person
and I have once it needs and I have
priorities that I need to you know set
in front of yourself to understand what
I focus on and when they understand it
like you don't have to be the best in
every single thing but you make
trade-offs then they understand balance
better so I love talking about that
that's a good pillar as well that's such
an important one I think a lot of
entrepreneurs experience burnout toad a
lot of people even even people that work
just general like 96 also experienced
tons of burnout and sometimes doing work
that they don't love which is I and then
the there's a difference between
vitality and adrenaline because we were
running on adrenaline all the time you
have higher chance of burnout vitality
it's almost like an energetic flow
that's coming through you every day with
what you're doing now with this is
interesting so as in high school as
these kids are being morphed I mean we
just we just talked to Jared
yes but jared is Michael's son and
Michael's a patron of the studio and
Jared is very interesting 17 years old
and he is at design tech this the school
that that's all about project-based
learning and Design Thinking and so when
when when we talked to him about like
what he cares about what he's doing what
he's learning you know he's talking
about it from the perspective of kind of
what you described if like there's all
these stimuli that are coming in and
then he's able to kind of parse and pick
and do these trade-offs to figure out
what exactly he wants to go and and
pursue and that understanding that that
even exists in high school that's a yes
part of the process right we're not
really taught that buyer counselors is a
lot of it is that push that you were
talking about as well which is the Oh
like you know you're good at math so
like you know here's all this
engineering which is good like give me
that that's important but also be like
by the way you can throw art in there
piano music in there yeah you can go
throw nature in there right what happens
then right yeah and that's what I want I
want the youth to understand that like
it's okay and like don't worry when you
start to see different things that
matter in your life because that's what
life is
it's a balancing act and I think like as
an entrepreneur we both know the
struggles that come with that right and
just that come with trying to find
yourself and through the ups and downs
of being an entrepreneur because it's so
volatile and so you know yeah it's a lot
it's a lot that goes into
and youth to kind of like bring it to
their lifestyles I think it's really fun
because it's just like it allows me also
to look at my life back then in a
different way
because I'm like putting so much
attention and so much work into
analyzing the lifestyle of being a youth
right up being in high school and being
in college and trying to like say hey
your lifestyle is just as in need of
support and happiness and balance as any
adults and this is crucial because it's
coming into the the minds of thirteen to
eighteen year olds yep right that age is
so important to be hearing about these
things because we're that's why you know
we have we've had a 17 year old on the
show we talked to these 17 year olds we
talked about the way that they engage
with each other even one of the
questions that we asked em see hi the
the young rapper from North Bay that I
showed you earlier yeah that one of the
questions out we asked him was about you
know how often do you talk to your
friends about these more meaningful
conversations yeah and it's the same
[ __ ] that we used to have when we were
in school right majority of people are
not talking about them at all you know
how do we change that and I think the
way to change it is to let youth know
that they are people intellect make sure
that they don't identify themselves with
huge societal you know images that that
allow them to be defined by those images
we need to let them know you're human
and when you realize you're human and
there's so many different complexities
just in and of you you're like hey I
need to explore Who I am I need to talk
about that I need to resonate with other
people because you can learn from other
people and when people see me up on
stage they're like he isn't that old
ready not too long ago maybe graduated
from college and and I want them to see
that like I'm thinking like this you can
think like this too and it's in no way
taking away from your youthfulness right
or the ability to be young and to like
be carefree because you can do that too
but it's also so important to focus in
on your health and your success and
matters and I don't I don't ever push
success or any specific definition of
success on the students I tell them tell
me what you want to be right because
that gets them going it gets them
thinking mm-hmm yeah yeah Ronnie used to
want to be a janitor remember I still do
I could have been a janitor you can do
it instead of mine I gotta do this crap
silly video production stuff isn't that
interesting Ron it was a woman one of
your teachers in the third grade yes
Ruth Southwick said no wrong he don't
want to be a janitor you wanna you got
some talent you got some skills you
should you know be an actor but that
didn't like I said I could have been a
janitor I should have just stuck with
that rather than listen to her her these
these sort of influences so the the
research is very clear that the
influence that a young person has
between my 13 and 18 either a family
member or a peer or a counselor relative
or somebody that they just look up to in
general that if one of those things is
in the puzzle that helps motivate them
to see that they can achieve that goal
that they've set for themselves they're
much more likely to go and do it like
going like go and start the business or
go to a car show that's outside their
hometown um things like that so so that
should work like what you're doing screw
show okay so we got you know the
workshops workshops happen both at high
schools but they also happen at
corporations like yes absolutely what
what is what's the difference between
when you go into the high school for the
youth which is crucial yep and what is
the difference when you go into the
corporate setting for sure so when I'm
at a high school like I was just at Los
Lunas high school in Albuquerque New
Mexico so just like being there is much
more an educational vibe and so I was
there with the technology Student
Association and so being in a place like
that that's very much you know
educational you have staff who are
teachers and maybe like organization
advisors and it's the same content
but just like a different type of feel
and so when I was there I gave a
workshop on brand management and I also
gave a keynote and it was just kind of
like good to be where they are normally
because it kind of like it's like me
coming into their space and I'm able to
kind of like reflect back on my time as
a kid and just like being in high school
and what it meant and and just make it
it makes me feel like even more
connected to the space at the time in my
life when I was there but then at Google
right like where I've done a lot of work
with like you coming to campus it's much
more you know professional and there's
definitely an agenda in terms of just
like we want the students to know that
they can be the next you know software
engineers or the next you know software
developers and so it's much more like
hey we want to give them information
that allows them to see themselves in
this light and but whenever I am like at
Google doing a presentation like that I
always do infuse my personal forever
phase you know type of slant or pitch
which is more so about like what do you
want what do you need and finding that
happiness if it is through engineering
than it is or if it is through finance
and it can be that way too but I always
try to infuse that yes to give it a
little bit of art music nature in there
as well it's all their different aspects
of life that they can pursue that's ok
cool cool now now what would you say is
the important thing to be communicating
to the youth with the proliferation of
exponential technology yeah I would say
with the proliferation of exponential
technology it's really critical to let
youth know that their minds I believe
are the most powerful tools right so
even though we have all this technology
and so many apps being developed and so
many you know new features I think that
it's important to know that your mind
has the ability to connect the pieces of
the puzzle and to make this world
no one ever thought it could be and so
if you continue to feel that way you can
be fueled to learn more about these
technologies to work with these
technologies and to become a key player
in the future because you know that you
actually have the ability to make an
impact I think a lot of times people
think oh you know we're such a smart
society we're already here everything
has been developed there's no room to
grow and that's totally not true because
if you get your hands on this
information in this education you can
develop whatever it is you want to and I
think that's super important to stress
to the students and I think something
else another topic another vertical that
I focused on is achieving internship
success and internship success
internship success and so this is more
so geared towards well when I was in
high school I did an internship but more
so it's geared towards those students in
college right who are going off to
internships and looking for that those
full-time roles that could jerod that's
in the design tech school they go over
four times a year and do immersive
internships in high school yes yes so
it's there right and it's needed because
you need to be able to see the
technology and touch the technology and
see where the future is going the
mentorship to the mentorship right and
it's like also important so I'm also
always like pushing students to know
that like the future is theirs you know
it really is and then what about
specifically with like artificial
intelligence and robotics yes what would
you say is these crucial like robot
proofed skills that can that is
important to communicate to youth to
develop so that they're not focused on
doing repetitive work but that they're
focused on doing maybe more creative
work yeah I would say that you need to I
guess like just to get more clarity
around the question are you saying just
like okay within robotics what things
they should focus on in terms of like
the spectrum of of like learning maybe
more so that because AI in robotics are
about to be taking away a lot of like
taxi driver jobs and truck driving jobs
all or white-collar stuff now like this
is all really about to happen the next
couple of decades
kids that are being born today yeah are
gonna be 18
20:36 ah-choo that's gonna be crazy yes
they're gonna have to be learning
completely different things so like what
kind of advice would you would you give
absolutely I would say you definitely
need to look at the current job
landscape for what it is and understand
it completely because if you think about
like you said all the robotics in the
technology that's happening today and
how you know industries are being
completely wiped out and some industries
are being completely created right based
off this technology you need to be able
to position yourself and this is
something I'd love to talk about
position yourself is a key asset right
and it's being very truly valuable and
the way you do that is in a lot of
different ways one way is to understand
all the technology to get the education
to be equipped with the ability to
answer any question that comes your way
but then another way is to truly dive
into the relationships like you said
mentorship is pivotal so if you have key
mentors in different industries right
you have tons of connections remember
when we connected at the World's Fair
and you were just like you had all these
connections with all these people in
different industries that's still
important because those people can not
only pour opportunities into you they
can pour even more knowledge into you
and so it's important to like have the
hard skills right be able to you know
manipulate spreadsheets be able to
calculate and crunch the numbers and to
do you know the stem type of skills but
then also develop those relationships
make yourself a person who has a brand
that everyone can resonate with and that
people just genuinely enjoy working with
mm-hmm
yeah I love the words key asset make
yourself a key asset yeah damn that's
really insightful totally man and it's
true because if you think about these
big companies you are a tool and you
have to do you know what it is that
you're meant to do and I think you know
me being at a big company I also love to
focus in on you know what it is that I
love about me and what's truly me that
can beef up me doing the job that I have
to do and I think that's the way you
truly win right because I don't like the
fact that you know some people feel like
oh if I go to work I'm only there to
work
no go there to do the job but think
about the job in a different way think
about how you can bring the true you to
the job and be happy and passionate
while you're doing it so you can truly
live you know it's almost like thinking
about the job like you are a key part
greater bigger picture yes yeah right
you're not just like being used
you're like a partner Yeah right yeah
yeah exactly yeah it actually makes the
world go round
a lot more efficiently and less
stressful E yeah when people feel like
they're human like you said and they're
human working together yeah and the less
that we see megalomaniacs the less we
see people trying to abuse like
kleptocracy the less we less we see like
kleptocratic power being abused just
their own personal gain and things like
that and the more we see people striving
to actually find that bit of humanity
within each other yeah that and that
that's communicated over media I think
the more we'll think of each other as
you know partners and working together
building a better world and less so in
wanting to climb in the race and get on
top of each other and all that stuff so
exactly yeah key asset that's really
important actually I like that way of
understanding the focus for children and
the young adults in their pursuit of
careers is to think of themselves as a
key asset where can you be a key asset
in which like you said which industries
are coming to a close which industries
are coming to arise how can you be a key
asset and no industry is coming to arise
right yeah yeah and every day I
personally think about this you know
like I'm at Google I worked there but
then I'm also this motivational speaker
and I love doing this and so I told my
manager you know like I love speaking
this is what I feel like is a part of my
DNA to be inspirational and to help
people and it's just like he understood
that and he supports that and it's just
like now how can I put this into my
current role and that's why I'm doing
like more events on campus thank you
to them because it's just like if you
already have connections in some way to
the thing that you want to do dig into
it and fully you you know experience it
and figure out how you it can benefit
you right so yeah yeah thanks for
pulling this one up Ron this is really
relatable to what we're talking about
right now so then this is this is when
when people are coming out to campus and
you're able to talk to them both about
the importance of the future
technologies all these really important
jobs of total engineering design and
operations and all these new things that
are coming up but also you're able to
plug in some of that forever face energy
some of that motivation as well yes yeah
yeah and like this event was actually at
Stanford University so they have the
black college fair every year and so I
went on behalf of Google just to
represent you know the company but also
to just talk about my college experience
and so when I get here in these spaces
representing Google but also infusing my
language and my purpose with forever
phase I think it really touches the
students in a different way because it's
just like they see Google and they think
one thing but then they here forever
phase right completely different they're
just like wow like what is this forever
face thing mean like how did you create
the company and what does it mean it and
so it can be together - it can be
together right and that's why I love so
much like being at work and being able
to do what I love because it's truly a
part of me and I feel like Google you
know fully understands it you know and
so whenever I'm talking about motivation
whenever I'm talking about
hey achieving your dreams and not
allowing your success to be a phase but
making it forever like we hear that all
the time in different ways we're all
saying you know the same message but
it's in a different manner and so it
just gets me excited to be able to to do
that let's let's pull up a couple of
other photos cuz I ever oh yeah yeah I
want to look through some of the other
ones for sure yeah I feel like um you
know this year especially this was at
Google this was the tech day which was
super neat you know we had
youth coming from all around California
and hell above here you know I'm
literally Jim man I've been in the Geo
fake Salafist and then I really been
working doing it you know but yeah this
was a day where we brought like over 500
students to Google's campus and we were
just like working with them on
understanding technology understanding
how to code understanding what different
careers exist and I was the kickoff
person so I kicked off the whole program
got the students excited yeah closed it
sat on the panel it was great man and so
yeah things like this just really gave
me excited you know Helia aha that
sounds so great that's a person event
with all these young kids yeah yeah in
this but I think what really touches me
though is like when I'm at a high school
and sometimes at a corporate event but
when I'm in high school specifically a
lot of times students will come up to me
after and they'll say like hey Greg like
I have this personal situation going on
in my life we're like I don't know if I
have balance I don't really know how to
get it and it's kind of like they can
fighting me for a quick second and they
just like want somebody to talk to
because maybe they don't know who to
talk to about these things because we
just said like we are having those
conversations in high school and so it
just like makes me realize okay Greg
this is your opportunity to really help
make a positive impact on this person's
life so I always like hope I say the
right thing and I'm just like confident
and just like pushing a message that I
believe will help them make better
decisions you know yeah I wonder how
much and this is at Google IO right yeah
oh yeah yeah I wonder how developed the
mind of like a 16 year old is to be able
to be very analytical of the of the
design of social media mm-hmm right
because when we become like 25 and so we
get we get a more analytical mind we're
able to see like the the ways that we're
being manipulated with technology for
our attention totally yeah so he can
make advertising dollars so we we were
starting to understand this more like do
16 year olds like can they
can they really analyze that and they
get it and then do they have the space
to talk to people about it absolutely
they understand I feel like a lot of
people you know don't really know or
they may not understand how smart these
young high schoolers are but they know
right like they understand the power
that you know the different apps are
having on their life and like how much
time is being taken away from them
because they devote it to these
different you know technologies and just
like social you know platforms and they
know that it exists but I think they
don't always have the power to find
something else to counter it right or to
take their attention and put it towards
something that they really want to be
doing because it's so easy for them to
get wrapped up in the images that they
see on TV or in social media and they
feel like that's the most important
thing but when they get into a space
like one of my workshops or they hear me
speak about my life and how I kind of
fought through the peer pressures of
being a teenager they realize hey there
are other things that matter just as
much as having a picture with eighty
thousand likes right that I could be
focused on and then we start that
conversation so they're definitely able
I think it's more so about providing the
places and the spaces where we say hey
it's okay to talk about this it's okay
to find out your passions and not to
just be bogged down in social media I
really want to make that message clear
for the youth that's so important
because it's only getting you've heard
of sesame credit in China I've heard
it's like social credit ranking so the
more that you do you know socially good
things the higher your credit is the
more you're going to get rent a car to
go do whatever you need to do in the
lower your these social credit ranking
is the less you're able to do those
things I know Ron might have something
to say
yeah well I um I believe the children
are our future and we should teach them
well and let them lead the way show them
all the beauty they possess inside give
them a sense of pride make it easier let
their let their laughter remind us how
we used to be that's beautiful it's
lyrics to Whitney Houston side greatest
love of all come on Oh
let's pay attention yes all this beauty
on the planet and we want to show kids
that all the beauty but also show them
that they can achieve their fullest
potential
right and when we show that to them and
foster a world where it's easier for
them to do that yeah then that's that's
good but then Ron there's also the side
of the world that's not so pretty yeah
right so then how do what do we do about
that well just let them know that they
can be part of that as well the ugly
part of the world if they want to be you
know criminals or drug dealers or you
know whatever that you know that's an
option as well that's raw - yeah just
just be like this is straight up like
some of the darker part of the world and
sure mass you you know the big thing is
you know serial killers you can inspire
them to be part of that in wouldn't you
have to know that like in the real world
right like there is light in there is
you know like things that are there
there are things that are good and
there's things that can harm you and
like can put you in a bad situation and
I'll let the students know right like
it's not always easy and this I think
comes more so through much stories when
I just like tell them like hey these are
some of the things I went through that
we're challenging or things that really
helped shape me into the person I am you
have real interactions and if you make
bad decisions you can end up in a bad
place and it's just it's just the way it
is and so I think it's not okay to
sugarcoat things for students just
because you think that you don't want
them to
to be exposed to it right too soon
because in reality they probably have
already found out or they know that
these negative things exist and they are
they might be curious right as we all
are curious human beings and it's good
to stay like hey fight for what you
believe in fight for what's right fight
for what you know can put you in the
place of your dreams in the future
because if you choose to get involved
and you know bad peer pressure if you
get involved with drugs and you know you
want to do negative things your life can
take a totally different route that's
right
that's right we got to let them know
they're nobody until they start smoking
cigarettes and not getting tattoos I
really I really like that like if you
teach the children like both of these
perspectives then the kids are you know
you're not shutting them out from either
one you're just giving them the
opportunity to choose either one okay
let's do a couple of our let's do a
couple of our simulation questions all
right on on the way out and I'll go
ahead and Ronnie do you want to give us
our shoot pressures on ding ding ding
yeah I really love that our glass is so
nice yeah here we go come on you dirty
rat bastard yeah my John we if we have a
fun noise for the 15 minute period okay
it's like things get interesting now we
now we enter in okay okay so let's start
with this so the there's a lot of
inequality going on yes an equality of
opportunity totally not not equality of
outcome not that at all equality of
opportunity so it's a lot of inequality
going on and there's let's take the
United States for example but it's
different in all different places in the
world
so we got a lot of people that have a
little and a very very few people that
have a lot and now exponential
technology is making that even greater
the gap the bottom is still coming up
with the gaps becoming greater what are
your thoughts about inequality how do
how do we handle that I feel like my
thoughts around inequality are really
grounded in the humanistic principle of
doing good and of just having love in
your heart because I think everything
that I do and everything that I'm saying
and that I'm just like influence tudents
to do it's all coming from like good and
love and so I think that if we as a
people think about what is embedded and
good and embedded in love you can do
things that help push the needle towards
the right direction in terms of giving
everyone opportunities and in terms of
like trying to you know break these
inequalities down in a way that is fair
right and I think that because there's
so much inequality things are just
completely imbalanced in some parts of
the world and the people who have the
resources to help I feel like should and
we should always be looking at ways to
give back and to understand the problem
and to understand how as we develop
these new technologies right as we push
the world forward it doesn't always have
to mean that someone else gets pushed
out right if we're truly as smart as we
really are
we should be able to figure things out
because we figure out everything that's
super complex right and so I think this
is just another problem like let's solve
it and I think we shouldn't be afraid
and we shouldn't be lazy to pull up our
sleeves and say like let's get to the
root of the cause and let's try to fix
it I like how you said that that just
because I am moving up doesn't mean I
need to push someone else out right that
if we're truly these now hyper
intelligent animals on this planet you
know then let's figure out how to uplift
everybody I really liked the one of the
answers that we've had to the wealth
inequality was right now wealth and
qualities like super rich and super poor
the idea was to do like like this it's
like just close the gap where he's super
rich too before just close the gap but
move everyone up at the same time so it
just makes the bear level like really
really high but keep the wealth
inequality continuum wealth continuing
to increase as well right yes and so I I
don't necessarily know I don't agree
with that completely because I think
that we shouldn't look at it as though
as in like let's just like make the rich
richer and like let's make the poor a
little richer but then like still have a
gap I think it's about like let's see
what it would take to give those poor
people or the people who don't have all
the opportunities to give them the
education and the opportunities that
they need so that one day if they really
worked hard or if they really you know
got all the resources they have they can
they can get there too right
understanding that the probability might
not be as high but I think it's more so
like let's give people the resources
when they you know enter college let's
give them the tools and education to say
like hey you can achieve anything it is
that you want to I do think we were
saying the same thing there because yeah
from yeah from that from that lowest
level of inequality up until up until
here we're where we were moving them to
that process was those tools and the
resources that were needed to bring the
bare level up so that everybody at least
has access to clean water and clean food
and shelter and clean air and then
education and health care and things
like that on the whole planet and then
from there they just the gap itself is
just smaller so that way it's easier for
people to become actualize with that
opportunity that they have got you got
you guys yeah ok I thought you were just
saying like let's just like put them in
like a better situation but like I guess
the way we do that is through the tweens
right totally yeah yeah yeah ok now
let's ask you about what is the most
beautiful thing in the world
oh let me think the most beautiful thing
in the world I would have to say just
like peace you know just like being at
peace true tranquility and just like
understanding that like everything's
gonna be okay
is truly beautiful to me because I think
that um when you're at peace in a world
full of inequality and full of you know
just like things that are harmful to you
having a sense of peace that's within I
think it's beautiful because that's like
no one can take that from you so I think
that's you know think yeah it's like
radiating with such a sense of
equanimity that no matter what happens
on the outside world that you are
retaining this peace that's so important
and not and I talk about that a lot
because I talk about students being able
to like have ownership of their
emotional you know reactions and I talk
about emotional intelligence and just
being able to own that it's so key
because this world is fuelled with
stimuli that are gonna make you it some
stimuli that's good and it might make
you happy and it might make you sad but
I think it's good to not allow anything
to impact you too powerfully right like
I wouldn't want anything to make me too
happy because there's the ability for
that thing to go away and then it might
drive me down so like just kind of
control that internal peace yeah yeah
that's a great answer I love that one
I'm always so grateful for everyone's
answers to this question because they're
always teach me I love it
just basking the in the question what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
yeah because there's so much right it's
like yeah anything what do people choose
what have they chose we've had a lot of
people say like you know love because
you can't like see it
you know I feel it we've had a lot of
people say consciousness the fact that
we were given the ability to perceive
the cosmos and interpret it that's been
a really good answer yeah gee cheesecake
mmm most beautiful thing in the world
Ron cheesecake is very beautiful I'm
like I'm like Ron I love you and Ron's
like I love Chinese food that you know
some things you can't do not yeah love's
a strong word but but you were actually
mentioned that the more that we feel
like the humanity the real raw humanity
yes that that is actually how you can
prevent people from being pushed out and
yeah bring people in yeah yeah that's
what I want that's truly what I want
like as I live my life I want people to
see me and think Greg is a real guy Greg
is a genuine guy and Greg spreads this
energy with every single person he meets
because that's who I am
and that's what I want to give out into
the world and I feel like the more I put
that out there people will see it and
they'll start having real connections
within themselves and it's just like the
more we connect that's powerful man
because we're all him and we're all
going through the same life or not same
life but the same human experience but
in very different ways but if we can
connect that with the fact that we're
all human there's so much that's similar
in that yes so the humanity connecting
us yes yeah mm-hmm
gosh that that's another really good
part of the wealth inequality equation
of how to converse with people about it
is you know you're human I'm human or a
human you know
you wipe your butt after you poop just
like me right you know doesn't matter
how much money you have it does that he
does that he does it you know and I
think like and even when people you know
I think it's also important to look at
our skills from a humanistic lens
because it's just like okay you're good
at this
I'm
at this let's respect the fact and
appreciate the fact that we can have
differences or different skills that
were both really good at yeah yep
all right let's ask you a next question
is are we alone in the cosmos
are we alone in the cosmos how would you
define the cosmos
just like here are we alone as humans
should do is there are there other
beings of some sort yeah that's the
question are we alone I say this I say
we are not alone because I believe in a
higher being I believe in I believe in
God definitely believe in God and what
does that look like to you what does God
look like to me I feel like God is so
big that there is like nothing that can
really define God and like there is I
feel like it's all-powerful right like
when I I just love and I love the
ambiguity you know I'm not one to say
that I need to know what that thing is
in the university because where I feel
like we're not alone because we know
that um so much more exist and I love
the fact that that's true and so I just
really believe that yeah with the so
much more existing what do you what do
you think does exist on those rocks
orbiting stars and the other parts of
this galaxy and other galaxies yeah okay
I feel like other creatures
it definitely potentially exists you
know like we just need to we need to go
there and find out and like do the
research and like get more insights and
more clues but um I don't know I would
think they were probably okay I wouldn't
say there we have like full-blown like
people that are functioning that we just
don't think are humans I would say there
are things like organisms like there's
some form of maybe life that exists or
maybe life that's advanced
that's a possibility and who's to say
that what we define as being the most
advanced you know human is actually what
they would define as that you know like
what if it's something that we would say
is like less advanced but they think
it's more advanced and like like whose
definition is right and why is our
definition always considered right yeah
you know yeah we're so ignorant ignorant
Marcus but this there's no even if
you're even if you're slightly
intelligent you're still vastly way more
ignorant right then smarter you are
usually the more you understand your
ignorance all right this is like so much
more they're so much more yeah okay how
about we go to our last question which
is are we in a computer simulation are
we in a computer simulation is this some
huge game huh that is that the question
I say we are in our own individual
computer simulation and I like to think
is my life like that because I don't
like to think that don't look at all the
other Gregg's in there right right this
is my simulation yeah I feel like you
know I'm not I feel like the world
doesn't revolve around me and I don't
like to think that but I think my
individual life is a sequence of events
that are very much so like a game and
like a simulation and and you need to be
able to play it and play it well
according to how you will respond which
the world doesn't know but only you know
and so if you understand how you'll
respond you understand the events that
are coming you make the right decisions
hey it could be a simulation mmm
describe it as a game you think that
every time that you have more
perseverance and grit and you succeed
you would go persevere through that yeah
level up yeah yeah say my mom would be
super happy right now because my mom and
this isn't what I must
teaches that I always say I say my mom
told me when I was young she was like
Gregg in life you have cushions and you
build these cushions up every time you
do something right every time you do
something good every time you're walking
on the right path and you determine what
the right path is you didn't never
actually never told me what it was but
she says when you fall when you make a
bad decision when you feel hurt when you
feel down you'll and you don't want some
cushions you never hit the bottom you
never hit the bottom so I absolutely
look at life as a constant process of
walking up stairs or winning in a
gamification mode right because that's
how we should view it I believe that's a
part of the motivation you got this far
because you never gave up because you
keep walking forward living that forever
phase walking there forever phase make
your dreams come true right it's a
process we're gonna watch that movie
yeah let's do it yeah and that was a
good way to transition into yeah it was
just like boom yeah yeah yeah this is it
hello I'm Greg Hammonds founder and CEO
of forever faced LLC I created the
company in 2014 with two main goals in
mind I wanted to fuel my passion for
entertainment and I wanted to inspire
youth to achieve a higher education and
a higher purpose for their lives
a lot of people ask me what is a forever
face and forever face is two main things
a state of mind in a way of life it's a
state of mind in the sense that when
you're in your forever face you think
critically about everything you're doing
and you constantly want to get better
you believe in yourself and no matter
what goes you said you know that they
can come to fruition because you're
constantly thinking about how to get
there and once you've clearly formulated
that mindset it leads into a way of life
because you change the way you act you
change the things you do in your
downtime and even when you're working
you're more productive because
everything has a purpose and you're in
touch with that when I'm in front of
students I cover topics ranging from
professional development to brand
management to public speaking and this
is to inspire them to encourage them in
an entertaining way but most importantly
to give them the tools and resources
they need to succeed going forward one
of my largest goals is for forever face
to have a global impact
this means youth around the world being
inspired and equipped with the resources
and the tools they need to achieve their
goals I know that in order to make this
happen I need to be on every platform
and every channel that exists so that
means TV film radio books you name it
forever face needs to be there and in
the faces and in the hands of the youth
in order to help them feel inspired
empowered uplifted and ultimately to get
them to where they want to be
so if you'd like to join me on this
mission of motivating inspiring and
empowering students check out my website
at Gregory hammers comm and reach out to
me a lesson bark upon this mission one
young person at a time
[Music]
yes that's it links in the bio go and
check it out go and reach out to greg
bring him in bring him around into the
groups that you have into both the youth
in high schools its corporate settings
as well and let's really get this sort
of notion of getting young people
especially young people inspired to be
at the fullest actualization that's it
that's what it's all about and that's
that's my dream you know if I can make
that happen and it doesn't mean I have
to be impacting a thousand people right
now because it starts with one person
right each portion at a time every
person on time one mine is worth a
million so and there's lots of Greg
Hammonds in other people as well that
are helping individually out so to
communicate even these messages to more
people to help have them help youth yeah
I love it people like you are helping us
build a bright future thank you so much
for thank you excited to continue
collabing getting some good stages set
up we've got work this duration yeah
let's get let's get more of these tough
questions as well yeah into the minds of
the youth let's do it go and maybe ask
them when you're on stage once be like
there's a lot she has to take a moment
and think what is the most beautiful
thing in the world you know just drop
drop a nice little simulation question
and everyone said oh I know let's see if
we can get you into like the design tech
school I was talking about going to a
talk there there's so many good ways out
we can collab I love your energy love
your vision love your vibe thank you
again for coming Thank You Alan I
appreciate it thanks for having and
thanks to the team thanks to Ron - oh
right oh yeah and thank you guys at home
tuning in greatly appreciate it if you
guys had a good time make sure to
subscribe like the video share it with
other people let's get more
conversations rollin about this stuff
also going create with this content
it'll just consume it but go and write
about it make a video about it start a
business where they go talk to youth
about it
go and create with this content and join
us on patreon when you continue
supporting the studio and also growing
the enterprise and impacting more people
so join us there much love everyone
[Music]
[Music]